assalamualaikum dear baby bros and baby
sisters
we're gonna be getting into
a little livestream today and last year
we wanted to talk about a uh
what did we want to talk about do we
forgot
it was uh
shaming tactics
that's what it was that's what shaming
tactics
but
aren't you uh go ahead hit it off
bro before i go in i had a question for
you
the first time you heard the word
shaming tactics what do you think it
meant
a tactic to shame
were you like the the
state champion of the spelling bee too
yeah
mashallah
okay guys so for a lot of y'all that
don't know what shaming tactics are
they're basically psychological
manipulative tactics that people use
society uses um a lot of different woke
cultural groups use them like the
alphabet people and all that and they
basically use these to make you
look like the bad guy
so it's kind of like i'll give a simple
example of this
um let's say
some guy
thinks that their spouse is cheating on
them right and they then go through
their phone
and they find exactly what they thought
was going on
and then the spouse comes and she's like
oh why were you going through my phone
you don't trust me like that's a shaming
tactic do you know what i mean
you kind of project
something else to paint the good guy
or the victim look like the bad guy
but anyway i got a list of typical
shaming tactics that a lot of people use
and we're going to be going through them
first first off
yeah
why do we want to talk about this what
what's the main
[Music]
goal here what where are we trying to
get across the main intention is i see a
lot of muslims trying to pander the deen
to please a lot of these woke groups
and they don't have this unapologetic
attitude anymore they don't have for the
deen bro so when a squad of the alphabet
gang comes along and they're like hey
you guys aren't inclusive you guys don't
value
humanity and freedom of choice and they
paint all these weird nice ways of
making you look like the bad guy and
you're out here putting a box like oh
damn like how do i am i actually the bad
guy do you know what i mean
but before we go in guys if y'all didn't
catch the umrah vlog check it out link
in the description
and uh
2022 take over time bismillah so
first one we're gonna talk about
the liberals use this a lot it's you're
barbaric or you're an extremist rami
what do you hear when or what do you
take in when you hear that from someone
or from society
what do i what i think when i hear that
yeah like if you're just you're being a
normal average muslim or you're trying
to propagate basic islam you're barbaric
you're an extremist
yeah i just see uh i just see a cop out
from having to
you know understand that people live in
a different way that anyone that lives
in a different way uh you know isn't
wrong and perhaps your way of living is
the one that's messed up i see it as a
cop-out to get away from religion uh
to you know it's a cop out to get away
from discussing something like you know
maybe capitalism is messed up maybe uh
what's it called maybe liberalism is
messed up maybe your secularist way of
life is not right maybe our religion is
actually right um and just because you
believe you're progressed and modern and
that you should have all these societal
diseases that you have without having a
problem with them it doesn't mean that
we are barbaric people and if uh if if
it's either you know being barbaric and
islam is barbaric and being modern and
living with these societal diseases then
i mean i'd rather be barbaric because at
least in you know
an islamic state we don't have these
problems that you suffer from but at the
end of the day it's a cop-out
alhamdulillah i know what's on your mind
when you hear that
that's the question bro
not what's on my mind but like
when i hear what what i mean when you
when you hear your your barbaric or your
old-fashioned or your extremist when you
hear this from world culture
when i hear extremists i completely
[Music]
disagree because they're just saying
that because they're coming from an
extreme point
if you think about it this whole
including and just
whatever it is that's going on
it's not really um
it's not really a balance it's not
really like the middle path if you think
about it it's actually a far off
it's it's dipping into an extreme in and
of itself you know so then when you are
in an extreme and you look at other
things then if they are not what you are
then for them that's an extreme
but it's kind of like romney said a long
time ago it's like when you dip to one
extreme
well or when there's an extreme present
you dip into another extreme or
something along the lines to correct me
if i'm coming around no honda bro i
think this is a very important topic to
discuss because a lot of people when
they hear these terms they actually
process sometimes that am i really the
bad guy like subhanallah there's there's
been a guy that uh in my family he he
prays five times a day now i'm telling
you guys this because i'm saying he's
doing the bare minimum as a muslim
mashallah may allah bless him because a
lot of people still struggle with that
but there were other people in his
family that were like bro why are you so
extreme
like why so like out there and i'm like
bro he's doing the bare minimum he's
praying five times a day and that makes
him extreme
that's what i'm saying though so when
you dip to one extreme then everything
else seems like an extreme
and then on on top of that you said the
uh what was the other stuff you said
you're old-fashioned
old-fashioned barbaric you're barbaric
you don't have an open mind
you're not progressive
yeah again this this will come from that
extreme because we're not a part of what
they are on
you know but like if if you get anyone
that's
even remotely close even if they're not
a muslim they're not going to say that
it's extreme they're not going to say
it's barbaric or that it's traditional
they're going to be like oh it's proper
it's not it's not my belief but it's
proper
yeah yeah and also it's a big it's a big
uh matter of being uneducated
essentially
um and it's a matter of values at the
end of the day because like even the
term progressive like what what does
that mean a lot of the time people
define there's a book i ran on i think i
mentioned it a few times i'll put in the
comments shout out if i remember
but it's basically talking about what
progression isn't and then what
progression is because people define
progression as how many university
graduates we have how many jobs we have
how our you know economy is how strong
our military is
are standing in the world are we in a
first world country or third world
country and so on and so forth
and they don't even define it using you
know how many natural resources you have
because you have you go to places in the
middle east that are rich in natural
resources rich in oil and stuff and
they're deemed like horrible places to
live
because the economic state they're in
but if you look at what progression
shouldn't mean improv but what
progressiveness should be it should be
that the government loves the people and
the people love the government and they
live in a cohesive manner where
everyone's benefiting the next person
and not this liberalistic mindset so
it's all a matter of what you see as
progressive and in my opinion based off
the definition i gave the muslims as
they proved for a thousand years would
be the most progressive nation on the
face of the earth as in the first
in the first few hundred years they
progressed science and
in mathematics and all these different
fields uh by some people say 300 years
without the muslims we'd be 300 years
back in terms of our scientific
technological advancement so i think
bro if you look at australia right now
the most woke liberal one of the most
woke liberal nations today
they're putting
first nations aboriginals
into concentration camps the ones that
get coveted this is on the news if you
don't believe me
normal people when i say normal people
i'm talking non-indigenous australians
right they're not going into camps but
these people are it's pretty weird bro
anyway uh we're gonna go through all the
isms right so liberalism socialism
feminism all the shaming tactics they
use um before we go into feminism
there's one more it's uh socialism and
liberalism they love this one it's
you're not inclusive
all right when when people hear that it
makes them feel like they're the bad guy
like they're they're trying to you know
have hate or marginalize a certain
population but we're better than that
we're smarter than that so rami what
does that actually mean
um well i mean again is i think i just i
just see it as another cop-out like uh
there has to be a limit somewhere this
is just uh trying to step beyond the
boundaries there has to be a boundary we
can't allow everyone in we can't allow
murderers and we can't allow rapists we
can't allow pedophiles we can't allow
people that go against the the morals of
society and any basic human being
who's not a
sociopath or psychopath would understand
that and they would agree that okay we
shouldn't i'd hope they'd agree that we
shouldn't let pedophiles in but they
should also agree that we we shouldn't
let murderers or rapists do whatever
they want and include them in our
society and to do whatever they desire
and with muslims it's just a step before
that we stop it at homosexuality
not just murder and rape but we stop at
homosexuality we stop it at public
displays of affection we stop it
at places well well before the um
uh socialists and the capitalists and
the liberalists we stop it at drinking
and watching pornography and all these
different things because these things
lead to societal diseases and these
things are very very problematic for
society as a whole especially in the
long term in the long run because you
look at the divorce rates look at the
pornography addictions look at how many
men are killing themselves look at all
the problems there are in society that
stem from issues um like uh even stds
come from homosexual people all of these
things these are societal diseases that
we allow to happen because of our lack
of morals so if you weren't if you're
not included it's not because we hate
you it's for the betterment of society
as a whole
that's fair enough i just want to say
bro a lot of people that are listening
to this right now that are probably from
will cancel culture they're probably
going to fit
everything we say or at least everything
we say is going to you know tick mark
all these boxes that we're talking about
subhanallah now what about you
well first of all it's not that we don't
include the people we just don't include
the act
we don't include the act of
homosexuality
the person and of themselves
they're included
but not the act of homosexuality and
that's the thing like
we're not inclusive this is just
referring to we we're not appealing to
the emotions we're not appealing to uh
your naps and your desires
right this is that it's that simple it
really is that simple it's always like
okay we were appealing to your desires
your lusts
your emotions
okay well
yeah you can be you can be a muslim and
you can be homosexual at the same time
like
well what does that do at the end of the
day it's gonna completely destroy
what a muslim is it's gonna corrupt what
islam is and that's what's happening to
whatever movements are being created
where
the
desires
are being at the forefront
but just having like actual substance
you know actual things that are set in
stone that don't change as time
progresses
fair enough bro
i know i know had a lot to say on that i
agree there's nothing else i gotta add
but
i know angel is gonna have a lot to say
on the next one too because he's
mentioned it before on the podcast but
uh this is a very common one that you
see
in uh
i hear a lot of you know feminists use
this but it's basically who hurt you
it's kind of cringe bro but it's it's
like
you're bitter or who hurt you
you know what do you
or at least what did you hear before
and what do you hear now let me know
y'all
um
i just see an attack on your character
an attack on your authority it's not
even a logical argument it's just like
trying to one-up you it's just a
one-liner like oh who hurt you like all
the masculinity is so fragile it's like
it doesn't really do anything honestly
on a logical irrational level like and
even if a person was hurt
what does that have to do with whatever
logical argument rational argument
they're making whatever case they're
making so honestly i don't even want to
talk about this one i think it's a waste
of time it's just a one-liner
it's just an emotional statement
it's basically like yo i have no idea
how to counteract what you just said
so i'm just gonna say who hurt you
and whoever else is uh
whoever else is listening
and watching in an emotional lens
they'll agree and they'll be like yeah
who hurt you bro come on like can't be
like that can't act like that
okay okay
all right let's go deep into it the next
one is
you're not supposed to judge a woman by
what she wears this is a very difficult
one to talk about subhanallah because in
islam we have the hijab we have modesty
and all that we have and in woke culture
it's more like
empowering oneself as a woman means to
not really care about that and to
liberate your your physical appearance
and sexuality so what are your thoughts
on
that no i think you should take this one
first bro yeah well this is shake
that was on youtube and he was asked
this question by a woman who was
basically wearing
uh a shirt with no bra and everything
and she is like oh why why do you guys
oppress your women
why do you guys make your women cover up
and everything like a woman should be
able to express yourself and be free
and
you know i'm not i'm not going to say
that i can remember everything he said
but one of the things he said
is like
every woman
nowadays
no matter where they're living they go
outside
okay let's say they're dressing however
they want to dress provocatively
whatever that's freedom for them
all right when it gets nighttime
go out into an area that's uh just a
little sketchy or go out into the city
or something and walk from like one side
or a few blocks or maybe a few like a
mile or something like that just walk by
yourself at nighttime as a woman dress
the way that you want to be dressed
provocatively see how that works for you
and like he basically
showed that like
you know nine times out of ten women
would do that
why wouldn't they do that because
they feel afraid that they would be
violated they would feel afraid they
would be raped or something would happen
why do they feel this way
because when a woman dresses
provocatively
is going to
instigate
a reaction from men
men we we respond visually we are visual
creatures so when we see something
visually that's appealing
we are going to respond now some men
have less inhibitions than others
some will resolve to cat calling some
will resolve to
um you know walking with you trying to
like talk to you like obviously the girl
here and then someone will actually go
out of their way and you know try to
make something happen
they'll try to grab you they'll try to
do whatever it is by force
and if you're alone if there's not many
people around and this person has bad
intentions you think they won't do that
you know and obviously women know this
intuitively they know this intuitively
that's why they are afraid that's why
they have that fear
now
if you look at the video that we made
the reaction where the guy he does the
experiment where the girl she's just
walking in like
not even provocative clothing i would
say like
normal western
normal western clothing and then she got
all these dudes hitting on her saying
all this stuff but then when the moment
that she covered up dressed modestly
more than hijab
it was nothing
it was nothing
i said there's reason behind this
there's reason behind this ramito tell
them the reason because it's slipping my
mind of why they did this back in the
day
back in saudi arabia
why they did what specifically back in
the day
why why the women started to cover up
why it was decreed for the women to
cover up inside
oh okay i see so like like the sharia
oh yeah saudi arabia wasn't
actually if you remember from the uh
from the class when it comes to the ella
the reason
um
allah doesn't provide an illah for the
hijab
but that doesn't mean that obviously
it's without a reason and we can't
derive reasons from it uh it's for the
sake of it it's because islam knows that
the social interrelationship dynamic
works best in the case where a man is
covering from naval to knee a woman's
covering basically everything except
their hands in her face
and there's limited interactions except
for what's necessary uh men and women
lower their gaze islam knows that the
social dynamic works best in this case
um
and uh
i mean look look at the problem like you
mentioned when you live in a society
where people can just
you know dress however they like
and if you know being if being clothed
less then i don't want to take from your
time you know
because i think it's still your turn but
if being clothed less means you're more
free then why aren't people walking
around naked why aren't people around
allowed to walk around naked why can't i
why not me you know why can't someone go
completely expose their
their genitalia and say that they're
free why are you oppressing me by
putting me in underwear you know what i
mean
sorry i want to give it back to you but
it's basically for the sake of paying
modesty
i agree with both of y'all it's it's so
superficial like the way they they
realize the way they handle societal
diseases is let's just appeal to
people's nufs today there's no
forethought in what could happen
tomorrow do you know what i mean it's a
goal they want to be free they want to
address how they want let them they want
to practice this let them they want to
drink let them but it's not going to
they don't realize what's gonna happen
tomorrow or even the day after when
subhanallah has has given us the perfect
instruction manual from jahiliyyah
to kiyama but if only they knew anyway
we got three comments from uh brother
abdul who's a youtube member shout out
to you let's go through it
so salaam alaikum brothers
and this political climate has created
uh
if you are not with us you are against
this mentality and the shaming tactics
help with this if you think the
government should provide social
assistance education health to the right
yeah like basically like if you want us
to help you out you gotta you know abide
by rules you gotta go get this job you
gotta do whatever
if you disagree with the alphabet
ideology to the left you were considered
a fascist that there is no middle ground
yet yeah yes
um i want to you know eventually bring
it back to the the question about like
modesty and everything but about this um
it's like this because you know people
have a tendency to make it this way
people have a tendency to make things
into a dichotomy and a lot of the time a
false dichotomy and the false dichotomy
today's that's either you're either a
capitalist or a socialist
or a communist you know what i mean
either capitalism or communism people
don't understand that there are other
things outside of communism outside of
socialism outside of uh capitalism
outside of liberalism secularism you
could just live in islamic lifestyle you
can have church not church but you know
sharia the sharia state islam majority
muslim country be the state live with
people who aren't exactly muslim but
still have a muslim lifestyle an islamic
lifestyle
using their rules and their norms
you can have a place where there's no
income tax but there's an
excessive
wealth tax
where you know things like
health care is provided for free there's
affordable housing you live in
essentially a utopia compared to where
we're living now and people might ask
you know how is this possible but even
that question is because they're coming
from a capitalistic mindset of the
individual but in this society it's more
about the collective so the the you know
everyone would literally be helping
their neighbor because that's the type
of society we live in and things like
that are praised and we're taught from a
young age to be there for each other and
not to just you know focus on you and
your money
around me going in on this one all right
so you also mentioned briefly the next
one or you didn't but there's no point
of me saying the next one which is don't
you guys oppress your women right so
there's no point in saying this one so
i'm just going to skip to the next one
you're in a marriage right now uh i
stuck for a lot there's muslim women
using this term but when there's a man
with
and you know the the society the world
culture they use this lot but it's
basically you're insecure
or you're controlling or you're
possessive
so when you hear that it almost makes
you look like you have a character flaw
now i'm not denying that there are i
guess spiritual disease of the heart in
islam in the deen okay there are i'm
talking extreme without any suspicion
without any evidence you're just here
being a lunatic we're not talking about
that we're talking about having basica
and they're saying you're possessive or
controlling
what
can i make one comment on the uh the
women covering up thing go for it bro go
for it
i just wanted to add something i forgot
to mention the beginning yeah which is
basically um you judge everyone based on
how they look whether it's how they
dress or how they act
everyone even women especially women
because they'll they'll they'll be the
first ones to go and tackle this outfit
so uh
honestly we're gonna
we're not gonna come out and like yell
at you in the street or anything but
we're gonna make an internal judgment
and it's gonna affect whether we wanna
even you know go near you or not so
that's just
there's clinical psychological studies
to prove that women judge women harder
than men judge women any day of the week
and you know we're not saying oh this is
what we're putting down but it's like
you combine that with the society that
women usually from what i've seen in the
west they give women compliments more
when they're not dressing modestly
so from a strictly behavioral
conditioning point of view
women are going to get that dopamine
spike when they dress this way and
they're not going to get it when they
don't dress this way and as human beings
we love attention so you know what i
mean but anyway the one you're true
controlling or possessive what are your
thoughts on the on ramy
you want to go first i talked quite a
bit
controlling your possessives
you know what the thing is
i think people are
i believe these people are not gonna
single out like women or men or
something like that but i think people
say this specifically
um because it they come from an
emotional standpoint
you understand what i'm saying like
if they're referring to muslims if
they're referring to like proper islam
and then they're saying are you being
too controlling you're being too
possessive it's like
okay well
this has been here for like
hundreds of years
this has worked since the beginning so
why would it not work now
oh it's not going to work now because
you're you you're emotional and you
think i'm being controllable and
possessive
like at that point like they need to set
their emotions aside and
really reassess everything just look at
it and then
you know see it from uh
i guess
i guess logical rational point of view
versus seeing it from a emotional point
of view and that's that's the problem
nowadays is that we live in the time
where everyone is just
everyone's emotional everyone's
appealing to the emotions like this
whole everything's just set up to where
it's like you have to appeal to
someone's emotions that might not even
be the proper word but y'all understand
what i'm saying
yeah
yeah no i agree it's like to whose
standards you know what i mean [ __ ]
american said this in a video where when
people use these terms
it's
they have an issue with the deen or with
the commandments that allah has given
but they project that on to you to make
you look like the bad guy for minor
kuffar right so if they have an issue
with allah giving divine revelation on
how a woman should dress and a woman
looks at you sideways for you know
reminding her of hijab you know even in
a polite way it's not her issue with you
it's her issue with hijab and people
would rather
subconsciously rationalize that i have
an issue with a human being instead of i
have an issue with allah's divine law
it's a very tough build as well for a
lot of people
yeah
100 subhanallah my two cents on it would
just be um
can you can you read the statements
again yeah so you're insecure
i.e one
man
you're controlling you're possessive you
you don't you don't trust me this is a
big one that i didn't mention but you
don't trust me
yeah yeah i'm alhamdulillah i just
wanted to be sure i'm i'm on the same
top alhamdulillah
um yeah so a lot of the time i mean i
like what both he said so i'm not going
to talk too much
but um
it's um
it's it's all it's kind of funny
actually when it comes to
calling a man possessive or controlling
or whatever because why is having this
form of of possessiveness or protection
or control bad why are these things bad
and a lot of the time some men are too
possessive
some men would just like lock the woman
in the house and like you you you're
never going to see you know the sun
basically yeah yeah and like that's okay
that's possessive that's too much some
men are too controlling like
no you have to do what you know aishara
dillahun once in a while where she
covered one eye and her entire face only
one eye was showing
you have to do that like
that's too much you you can't you know
force your wife in that case
but uh in in cases it's like i want you
to dress modestly i want you to do at
least what allah has commanded you
why bro this is the husband you should
want to have because this is not the
husband that's going to let you do you
know whatever you want this is the
husband that's going to you know help
you get to jannah this is the husband
that's going to keep your kids
from you know doing whatever they want
because if your husband is letting you
do whatever you want then he's not going
to have that
proper fatherly discipline
with your children as well and then
they're going to go off in that
direction as well and if you don't have
a man that's willing to stand up even
you know to you
uh
for the sake of allah for to establish
the rules of allah
then he's not going to do it for your
kids and that's not a man you want in
your life you don't i thought women
wanted a man who is in control of
himself and in control of the situation
i thought women wanted a man who who can
protect them
but it's only until they protect you
know they protect you from things like
uh well that's you know not modest
enough exactly
so now it's convenience bro i don't know
what's on your mind
no no i like that he's cleared up yeah
okay i was going to say there's a
brother on tick tock forest hamadi i've
been watching lately i don't know if you
guys know him but we're going to do an
episode with him inshallah next week but
he was making a video where basically
what rami was saying that that's
possessive you know where aisha's
was covering one eye
we're not saying you can't do that
because in islam
at least a woman has to obey her husband
provided it's
and if it's permissible it's permissible
so we're not saying it's haram for a man
to do that well necessarily what we're
saying is
by woke standards it is on the
possessive side compared to you know the
more that you do whatever side all right
next one this is going to be a weird one
because
this is kind of the contra positive of
what we talked about the opposite
it's man up
or you you know it is possible
before you even go into that
if we're talking about women here
women got to understand like men just
naturally have the hair
it's in us it's in us like this is
something natural
it's just we need to learn like what's
actually proper
and what's not
from the right
from the right people not from a society
that's been feminized
that's trying to
uh
feminize the man so it's like if you
take a man who has this naturally inside
of him and he's not able to express that
because you're shaming him you're
putting him down for expressing this
natural trait
that the creator has instilled inside
him
what do you think is gonna happen
nothing good is gonna happen and it's
not gonna go away it's not like he's
just gonna fully submit
what ends up happening is that it starts
to
affect him
psychologically in different ways so
where he's gonna act out and he's gonna
he's just gonna do things where this is
not
it's not good by any means and like what
is this gonna happen i don't know
but
if you if you have a man
like from my experience if you have a
man
he has this hater
and he's put down because of it he
starts to stop
being protective he starts to stop being
all that jealous and then starts
accepting everything so it's accepting
everything so okay then now the woman
gets to the point where like all these
men are trying to hit on
and now it's like well he's he's not he
doesn't have the jealousy he's been
suppressing himself so much that now he
can't do anything so now the woman's mad
at him because he's not doing anything
so it's like okay well what do you want
now do you want him to be protective do
you want him to have that jealousy like
that protective jealousy or do you want
him to just be submissive and then he's
like oh well no i want i want him to
have it sometimes but not come on now
yeah that's just playing with it being
youth won't get you far in the eyes of
allah from what i've researched so
that's what it is but anyway we got a
lot to cover so the man up thing what i
hear when i when i you know i get people
saying man up it's basically like oh now
it's convenient for you you know what i
mean like
you want us to let you know y'all do
whatever you want until it's man up time
there's another one too that ties with
this it's uh i want you guys to tell me
what you hear when you hear this it's a
real man does xyz or a real man is xyz
and
women saying this about a real man this
automatically it's like bro the
arrogance like you know you're not a man
but yeah what do you hear
well i mean i think it's funny because
as soon as they say a real woman does
this that's like they lose their mind
and then they say a real man doesn't
tell a woman what she is and isn't just
hypocrisy at the end of the day but
um listen i
i don't define what a woman is i don't
define what a man is allah to allah has
made it very clear the prophet
has made it very clear the boundaries
and things think about what defines
a thing
what defines a thing is it's its
boundaries what it can't be recognized
without for example
i can't be a man if i don't have things
a man has you know what i mean uh or if
i have if i also have things that a man
doesn't have i can't be a natural human
being if like i have like wings and i
don't have like you know
male genitalia you wouldn't consider me
a human man it doesn't make sense uh sit
now let's take physical characteristics
aside there are
behaviors and roles and in ways that we
act as men that allah
and the prophet said defined us to have
to have
we have to have
we have to have protectiveness and if we
don't we're literally less of a man men
have to go to war so if they miss out on
that without a reason literally they are
less of a man and men have to provide
and care for their women in a way that
women don't have to for men there's a
distinction between them so if a man
doesn't do that not because he can but
if he's not willing to if allah gives
him the ability and he doesn't he's
literally less of a man and same thing
with a woman allah has has made it very
clear uh what a woman should be like and
there's hadith
talking about it like she shouldn't be
as crafty as a man and she should really
care about you know how she looks to her
husband and she should really care about
looking pleasing to her husband and the
same way
not the same exact way but husband
should as well to the wife but it's
emphasized a little bit more for the the
the wife to the husband there are hadith
talking about it and these are things
that allah and the prophet peace be upon
him have decided so i'm not making it up
so when you come to me and say a real
man does this you might come to me and
say a real man lets his woman provide
for him but it literally makes
absolutely no sense in my eyes and since
you're basing it off of nothing but your
personal opinion i'm sorry but i don't
like i couldn't care less about that
i agree shout out to nayway for becoming
a youtube member and joining the family
bro or sis
now the next one is hold up boy you
ain't even let me go
oh damn bro this guy's a lot to say that
masha allah come on now i ain't got a
lot to say it's just very simple
it's like rami said
these people that are saying man up or
you know whatever it is
they don't know what a man is
they have no idea they're speaking
strictly from
their perspective their subjective
intellect
and it's like listen if we want to know
what a man is like
we have the proper guidelines
we have the proper role model that is
what a man
should be and if someone says oh
um you need to man up and do so and so
okay is that
is that what the
prophet muhammad peace be upon him did
you're not then
where are you getting this one
you know
all right
next one is
fragile masculinity bro i cringe i know
i'm cringing my skin is crawling but
fragile masculine it almost makes you
feel like as men we naturally have
masculinity as men we naturally want to
proliferate martial or masculinity and
when you hear someone say that you're
doing this because you don't have
masculinity it almost makes you have
like a mind bender like oh damn i should
be doing the opposite to show i have a
lot of masculine and a lot of men fall
victim to this right stuck for a lot of
youth men that use these shaming tactics
on other men today the male feminists so
on and so forth but when you guys hear
this term uh or this phrase what do you
what do you hear
don't know you want to take this one
first
now you can go bro all right
so um again i see another kappa i see
another it's in it's along the same
lines of a man does this a man does that
because when when you do something and
someone comes to you especially like
women or other men they say you know
that's just fragile
fragile masculinity it's the same thing
as saying a real man does this and that
when you call someone fragile and they
call them masculinity fragile because
something they did it's the same it's
basically the same as saying you're not
a real man so it's along the same lines
and i think it falls into the same
category if you think my masculinity is
fragile because i
have respect for allah messenger and for
my family and i want my wife to dress a
certain way and to not dress a certain
way and my kids to grow up a certain way
and not grow up some other way
then you know call it what you want to
but this is what literally makes me a
man
and if anything your men are the ones
that are losing their masculinity um and
literally becoming women honestly there
are some men literally becoming women
if anything if anyone's masculine is
fragile would be theirs so
turn your heads to them
[Music]
i don't have much to say
i think it boils down to the same thing
uh that i said where it's like if you
suppress
a natural trait then something bad is
gonna happen
and then the same as the other like
if it is suppressed and then now you're
trying to
tell them oh you're not even being a man
you're being
you're being
less of a man you're being like a woman
right you know i'm not gonna say the
word but
you know what i'm talking about the
people yeah
yeah yeah it's like
okay first you suppress the individual
now you're trying to get them to do even
more so now
anything that they do that is um
in their eyes
masculine
it's not going to be proper masculinity
it's just going to be
a shadow of masculinity and this is what
you can see as
toxic
masculinity this is like that forced
masculinity it's not real
but again it's like what rami said one
extreme breeds another
so if you suppress you're bringing this
individual to one extreme and then it's
just gonna dip them into another extreme
okay there bro next one
you're a misogynist
or the misogyny the patriarchy
all right it's found a lot you know
this question actually came up in a
group chat and one sister answered it
very well when it comes to patriarchy
and i don't think we have too long so
i'm going to try and make this really
fast but
islam is not patriarchal because
patriarchy has this like this male
superiority and this kind of like
females are undervalued narrative to it
but islam is not like that at all
actually um and misogyny some things are
misogynist some things that that men do
in the world are is misogynistic so i
mean we're not going to undermine that
but
um you would be undermining the term
misogyny if you take a man who asked his
wife to her hijab
and the man who beats his wife and call
them both the same term misogynist
it's actually disrespectful to the term
misogynist it's the same same thing as
like when a woman lies about being
abused you're actually disrespecting
real abuse victims who have to go
through it um because you
because i know you want a cop or
whatever so again calling someone a
misogynist just because you disagree
with them and because they have a
certain view about women sometimes it's
misogynistic but when it's based in
allah you can't call it misogynistic
because then you'd be calling allah in
the process of misogynistic and
that's a whole other problem i feel like
they would be called that today i stuck
for a lot in a lot of these terms but uh
anyway there's almost a hundred uh
viewers right now in the stream i love
about all of you guys smash that like
button just so we know that you guys are
still here with us all right just two
more
next one you're afraid of a strong woman
[Laughter]
oh man
it's not that we're afraid of a strong
woman we just don't want a masculine
woman because a woman can be feminine
and can be strong
yeah it is
yeah yeah and it's it's not i don't like
the term strong because it's not like
i'm afraid of a woman
who you know who's who's capable who's
who's strong or whatever it's on in my
opinion honestly it just gets annoying
to deal with a woman who's constantly
like throwing her you know herself her
opinion in your face and it's kind of
like competing with you i don't want to
compete with my wife and that doesn't
make you strong that makes you
disagreeable and it's really rather
annoying
so that's why i'm defining strong
that's a good question that's why i just
said oh not really but
that's what i had in my mind
mashallah okay guys we got four minutes
left do you guys want to open the floor
right now to uh the public or once you
guys go at 12 i just do that myself
let's let's open the four now inshallah
okay yeah last one
shaming is not really a phrase but
basically when women get shamed today
for wanting to start a family over a
career
[Music]
that's a big one man that's a big one
i'm gonna try and make it faster you
start while i change the thing to uh
subscribers too all right
um
it's it's it's really funny because
feminism is always you know let the
woman choose until she chooses to be a
woman let a woman choose until she
chooses to be you know a mother a
housewife not have a job and all that
stuff and i'm not advocating women to
not have a degree or not have a job or
anything they can they have the right to
do
um you know as long as it's halal within
the
boundaries they can do what they want in
that regard there's no problem with that
obviously when if the husband and
everything is okay with it
um but other than that you you like you
can't shame whether a man or a woman you
can't shame a woman for wanting to be a
housewife um the same way you wouldn't
want me to shame a woman not me but
anyone to shame a woman for having a job
or having a career
so if you're truly you know for women
choosing
whatever they want to do and being their
own independent people quote-unquote
then why can't they choose to be a
housewife and why is this bad because a
lot of women prioritize a career and
then they end up not having kids not
getting married and i've spoken to
some sisters in the comments that are
like you'll never catch me with a man
you'll never catch me marriage and it's
just very like hate-filled it's like
you know i hope insha'allah you find a
man that makes you see that not all men
are like absolute vile dogs
and there's nothing wrong with depending
on a man guys
whatsoever it's not about allah i'm a
bad man
yeah yeah that's true
but i'm saying like you can't have these
not experiences and then be like oh i
still want security what if it doesn't
work out i mean you're going into your
marriage being like it might not work
out yeah it's not really the right mind
state yeah and to be honest these uh
these women aren't really choosing
to go into work and all that stuff
they're being forced
by the society that they live in the
society is enforcing
them that like hey you need to be strong
you need to be independent you need to
make your own money you need to go out
here and you need to be studying and
getting the topic listen there's nothing
wrong
with these things inherently
but as a woman
i'm not gonna say much because obviously
i'm a man i can't speak too much from
the perspective of a woman but what i
will say
is that every single woman
that has gone down this path
always
says that they regret it
always says they regret i'm not starting
a family i'm not you know
doing things more traditional
if we want to say so and then also when
women are in this path
let's say you have a woman she's been
she went to school she's been working
full time she has no time for a man she
got no time for a family none of this
stuff
she gets sick
she has to take off like a week or two
weeks and in the week or two weeks
she's just spending time with the family
or maybe spending time with kids or
something like that like bro
she doesn't want to go back to what
she doesn't want to go back and do that
like that lets you know right there and
then like okay
yeah maybe she probably didn't like it
100 what she was doing but
it says a lot like it speaks volume when
a woman is in her masculine and then
she's forced to go back into her
feminine and then when she goes back
into her feminine she realizes oh i
don't really want to be in the masculine
this has just been something that's been
pushed on me
true i'm gonna quickly read out these
statements and we got some questions
from some sisters so people always have
something bad to say but our religion is
based on sincerity alhamdulillah it is
all right these people fail to realize
that there are men and males uh
allah has given us the character surah
man
masha
okay next we have a question from a
sister
would you say it's harder or easier for
a revert sister that's from a different
culture
to be submissive and righteous towards
her husband than a born muslim sister
i think it's hard
i think it has more
i think angel said he thinks it's harder
it's harder because i think it depends
yeah i think i think it depends more on
the situation because you can have
someone who's born into a muslim family
but the uh the women are taught
basically to be men and you can have
someone who's born into anomal family
but they're taught basically what islam
is in line with so i think it just comes
down to how you raise your upbringing
and all of that but at the end of the
day alhamdulillah people have the
opportunity to shape themselves over
time and if you change your morality um
then you know it becomes the door to
changing your actions as well opens up
so if you think a woman should be you
know submissive and righteous towards
her husband uh especially islamically
which is the case alhamdulillah
then you can definitely start to make
that change internally regardless of
where you are in life because allah made
the deen practical and easy and this is
what's in line with your your nature as
a woman anyways
it's still harder for the reaver though
yeah as a born muslim like yeah the
situation will
change
but as a born muslim like you have that
guideline it's there
and even if they're not truly like
following 100 to a t
it's still there it's still instilled in
them so it's in the back of their mind
and then when it's time to actually
submit they're actually more willing to
be
submissive to
their husband versus like a reaver woman
if she never had that like she has to
pretty much learn how to be submissive
if
her entire life she was getting the uh
the isms
i would actually disagree with you bro
because i believe that in a case-by-case
basis sometimes it's harder to unlearn
than it is to just learn for the first
time for example i see a lot of you know
go far women like non-muslim women in
the west there's this whole trad wives
movement they want to be traditional and
there are these non-muslims out here
let's talk about tajweed very simple
example not directly related but let's
say you were taught
wrong tajweed or pronunciation of quran
growing up so when you finally learn it
the right way it's like you got to
pronounce it a different way now the
correct way and it's going to take you
time to unlearn so similarly a woman
that's kind of been on dean even if
she's a reaver or not reaver but it's
been i guess shamed to be feminine for
her it might be harder to unlearn that
than a woman that never really even had
that guideline and she first came into
islam she said okay it says do this i'm
gonna do this right away like i've seen
a lot of women go into hijab within the
first week of reverting
so i think it does depend on the case by
case but something that that applies to
this case
in particular because the
revert
would also
have the conditioning
from outside so she already knows
something now she has to unlearn that in
order to be submissive and go into islam
bro every reaver has to unlearn what
they knew in order to accept islam
you know who comes to my mind with this
question sister naima because she's a
river isn't she
um
surround a lot sometimes i forget even
like brother gabriel that he's a reaver
yeah yeah
yeah yeah but you see and this is the
problem because we live in a
capitalistic society where like
if we didn't really if we didn't need
and love money before we really need and
love money now because that's just what
society is pushing out there especially
in a society where you don't have you're
not like you don't use like gold as
currency use paper
paper it's like societal and been
inbuilt uh currency essentially
something that doesn't have much
intrinsic value to it it's just
you know whatever they decide is is
worth something uh so it's not bad for a
woman to have
money to fall back on it if a woman is
truly scared about that she can ask for
a higher method or something that would
cover her for maybe a few months but
you guys are missing a big portion of it
because the job of a man isn't just to
provide financially it's also to
physically protect so if a man divorces
his wife she doesn't just lose that
income she also loses that physical
protection are you going to use the
maher to also buy bodyguards or
something like that so i think you guys
are missing the whole point uh when it
comes to this this topic as a whole
brother wasim writes overseeing writes
that uh
if a woman starts wearing hijab because
she's obeying her man
it's kind of like she's submitting to
him instead of allah like she should
already have that down pat and uh dr
stranger writes the same thing obeying
your muslim husband equals obeying allah
and a beloved prophet son so it really
is as simple as that um but it's harder
because we live in a different society
but it doesn't negate the fact that
what's right is right and what's wrong
is wrong
all right armored wolf writes they point
in the quran and say it's evil but they
never
seen the the torah or
man it's a different conversation man
that's more barbaric
uh
let's see
my last one i'm talking about swimming
keep you in your family
[Music]
like myself out of one truth whatever i
see
yeah guys i want you to you know anyone
watching this we made a reaction video
that aired yesterday
we academically refuted this this whole
channel
but check it out
i'm the love for the podcast
i think i think arnold's internet's
acting up
let's see what else there is
there's a lot of comments
um
no i agree
arami with this being said
how should a man a woman who wants to
hold tight onto the ropes of allah how
should they navigate life after hearing
what we had to say about all these
societal
i guess thorns
that are being just thrown at our faces
bro
for just doing basic things that make us
good human beings in the eyes of allah
well um
it is difficult because we're social
beings we want people to love us we want
people to enjoy you know what we do in
life we want people to even praise us to
a certain extent so it's difficult when
people are doing the opposite and
throwing shade at you for just living a
certain way especially when that weighs
what lost allah has decided not based on
our internal desires um but also it just
always goes back to allah you have to
strengthen your your understanding your
akida you have to strengthen yourself
your discipline and your just
understanding of islam in the world as a
whole
because when you understand there's no
legislator there's no one who can make
allah
a rule except for allah and you
understand that there's no one that can
make a way a deen or a way of life other
than allah subhana wa to allah then
you'll look at these people when they
disagree with you and you'll just
remember they're not coming from a place
of of logic irrationality they're coming
from a place of their inherent desires
and what they've been taught as
individuals and it didn't come from
allah what you have is from allah and
you just have to keep that in mind and
keep trying to teach them that way and
pull them to a saddam and if anything
influence them rather than have them
influence you
it's difficult it's an uphill battle but
it's just something we have to do as
muslims um
[Music]
mashallah bro uh ehb rights i'll watch
the podcast with us
unbelievably relatable martial i think
it was the one where we talked about
desires and nufs and all that so may
allah bless you for even watching the
podcast share with others
i don't know if you guys talked about
this already because i just came but do
you guys think it's wrong for someone to
force a woman to wear a hijab like his
wife or daughter okay so hijab is not
just something you wear it's it's like
characteristics of modesty it's like a
dress code in a way qualifications
criteria to keep in mind now when i i at
least i'm not you know i'm gonna give
the floor to rami but i i'm not gonna
speak on is it permissible or
impermissible what i'm gonna say is it's
easier as parents as husbands wali
to guide people in the right way instead
of getting to a point where you have to
i guess put force you know what i mean
like putting the foot down in and of
itself at times shows that you didn't do
your job when it was time to get stuff
done so my best advice would be
definitely you know conditioning and
raising them on dean properly to the
point where there won't be this whole i
removed my hijab when i was 18. you know
what i mean
yeah yeah 100 um and i think for the
wife and for the daughter is two
different questions and every case is
different every situation is different
and depends on the specific situation
when it comes to your wife or when it
comes to any woman who has reached i
would say above puberty who's at an age
where she kind of has certain desires
for herself and she kind of you know
makes her own decisions like oh i want
to wear the hijab now or you know
whatever decisions come to mind
uh it's never okay to force it on them
and the reason i would say that is
because they're going to go to hate
hijab and then it's
as by extension they're going to grow to
hate religion and maybe even you know
hey
so
you're not doing them a service think
about it what are you trying to achieve
get them to follow the religion of allah
you're not going to get them to follow
the religion of allah by forcing them in
the hijab even allah says
there's no compulsion in religion so if
you force it on them it's it's any if
anything it's going to be worse and ask
me
about this and he
he basically told us it's going to be uh
you know kind of like a slow game you
have to build up to it you have to
encourage them
and you have to be encouraging not
forcing but when it comes to a daughter
perhaps under the age of puberty someone
who's like you know six seven eight nine
old enough but still young enough you
can put the hijab on her have your wife
put the hijab on her have her go around
and she would be used to it by the time
she hits puberty and it would just be
something she's been wearing so in that
case i don't see a problem
fox
abu writes do you think the fathers have
ultimately failed their families in the
west i think that's a generalization but
i'm gonna keep going many okay yeah many
move to the west bringing their families
and have become misguided will they be
more accountable
as
kawamon
all right i think
i see this in a lot of desi households
and autumn households that it's like we
brought you to the west
there are you happy like this this is
our favor on you that we gave you an
upbringing in like such a progressive
liberal and safe at times um zone
compared to where we grew up
and you'll have a better education
better quality of healthcare better
quality of life at times and
there now kind of do your thing
i think people fail to understand that
you know back home they weren't very
practicing either especially if you like
in certain places because what happened
back home for the last few decades um
the orientalists the non-muslims went to
our land and changed our way
there were decades even my teacher was
talking about it
actually if you remember yesterday you
know um
brother farhadi was mentioning like you
know even in afghanistan the messages
were empty for decades yeah so these
people were weren't even ondine to begin
with exactly because the basically the
non-muslims came to kind of crush our
deen alhamdulillah it survived they
failed to crush it multiple times um but
i don't think it was much better back
then so we as students as people as sons
and daughters need to get our deen right
and help our parents if they're not
indeed inshallah inshallah bro i just
want to say martial you have a really
sick jacket bro i don't know why i just
noticed it right now
um but what you were propagating right
now aligns with this comment right now
so abdullah writes wallahi i swear by
allah i apologize to american muslims i
just used to think that american muslims
most of them are too liberally messed up
um and looking at your brothers and
others really change your mind
jazakallah first of all all from allah
alone second of all i will say this is
just me
i'm not going to make a whole
generalization but in other countries in
in the middle east the muslims i've seen
there do not compare in terms of manners
etiquette adab
iman and how how much of a good
community they have to some muslims in
the west some reverts
it's a shame but i'm saying it as it is
dr strange writes i'd be really it would
be really beneficial for the ummah if
there was a kind of islamic marriage
training program that young women and
men can join to learn okay so we have
made
an intimacy series right it's a whole
series a to z on intimacy raising kids
intimacy with your wife marriage night
nica pre naka screening everything with
brother gabriel romani i'll make sure to
link it right now if i can once the
video is done processing but check that
out go to our channel right now click on
playlist actually first of all find my
um vlog and watch that what are you guys
doing second go to playlist find the
intimacy series this is like eight or
nine episodes uh watch it with brother
gabriel and we have an episode that's
gonna air next week inshaallah that i
did in person with brother gabriel and
it's a continuation of the intimacy
series so you guys need to see that
um but
with brother fatis alhamadi the brother
from tic toc that i mentioned we are
going to film an episode exclusively on
the actual rights and responsibilities
of women and men in marriage
yeah yeah i just want to quickly add a
lot of people jump to the concept of
marriage but a lot of the time they
don't know that they need to fix their
akida first and that when they fix their
akida
everything the perspective changes for
everything
i agree
what are your thoughts on this comment
bro real quick
um well i mean it depends on how you're
forcing it if you're forcing it with the
aspect of fear like you're threatening
them then 100
and that's that's completely horrible
but um
i don't think i think force will always
denote some kind of fear and there's
different levels to it but um yeah i
agree that you they'd be doing it out of
fear and not out of the sick of allah
that would be heavily problematic
inshallah
that's funny bro i've never gotten that
you guys can do quran citation live
streams if you don't know arami has done
a little bit of a quran uh recitation of
an iowa 2 and it was very relevant to
yesterday's video the reaction video so
if you guys haven't seen that check that
out
inshallah
let's see okay so guys five more minutes
and then we got to wrap this up
what's going on well there's not much
what about you i see you in the comments
a lot allah mubarak
actually even in other countries except
golf countries but the situation is
getting worse for them too
i mean all right
cinemas writes i feel like being a
muslim in usa would be hard because the
left aka
jb is messing our school up with yeah
progressiveness yeah i agree it's
happening kind of too first of all shout
out to you i saw you on my uh vlog
channel i saw you commenting hello
mubarak bro double to you now but
what are your thoughts on uh on this
whole thing that's been going on because
i feel like um
may allah be pleased with him
he wrote
or he said this and it basically said
that the way to destroy a nation i'm
paraphrasing is to make adultery uh uh
fornication zina and all that normal and
widespread right and if you change the
youth if you change and brainwash you
know today's generation it'll be easier
to change tomorrow's generation instead
of already changing the adults and going
for the elders you know what i mean so
they know what they're doing but what
was your experience going to school here
in the west
um honestly just it was it wasn't as bad
as it is today alhamdulillah when i was
you know still in like you know primary
school and all that but
um
it was just very secular it was very
secular it was just very based on things
that you know they just wouldn't help my
my afterlife and
uh it's i think it's problematic because
a lot of um
a lot of the teachers are women and we
lack you know masculine male
authoritative figures in our life as
young men which is something that's very
necessary so on top of not really
learning what we need to learn um not
having access to proper islamic
education
and i'm not having good you know i'm
asking role models i think it's it's a
kind of a setup for disaster and then
they start teaching you about sex ed
when you're like in grade eight which is
like what 11 or 12 or something like
that it's um
it's really it's honestly a recipe for a
disaster that's true
all right first of all i want to give a
quick shout out to this brother so i'm
in uh in medina in al masjid anaboli
praying uh one of the prayers and a
brother literally walks up to me and
he's like
hey are you fired and i was like oh suan
allah and then he just recognized me
because i was posting on my story on
instagram when i was in madina and you
know he was a very nice brother
mashallah um very hospitable and i'm
really glad that you know you bumped
into me that day um to address your uh
your inquiry or whatever you wrote i
will agree with that and i'll add my two
cents that it's easier to find a woman
just like it is easier to find a man
that meets your criteria to begin with
than someone that promises to change or
someone that you see as potential like
as men we got to be objective if you
want a woman that wears niqab or hijab
and she's not already doing that before
marriage what really makes you think
she's going to do that after marriage
can it happen of course but you're
basically saying who you are right now
it's not who i want you to be and
therefore you have to change for me if
she hasn't already changed for allah
then i think that says it all
super chat from brother kaleb jazakallah
and you're a member may allah bless you
salaam alaikum a lot of the muslim and
the majority muslim countries take it
for granted i spent a few years in
somalia and it was awesome to hear the
adhan and being surrounded by all the
muslims very refreshing atmosphere man i
cannot even compare
living here to just my experience for
two weeks in madinah and makkah like bro
every single story on me closes down
around the prayers 30 minutes before
each of the five salah that's right
and five 30 minutes after
it just closed and during the whole
thing it's just you can't go you can't
go buy anything nothing
and the advantage is there everything's
there
um
you know internet like i'm scrolling on
instagram and just doing normal stuff
and a lot of the websites are blocked
and i'm just like bro this is how
society should be like it like a lot of
people will say this is extreme it's you
know no this is the way of life and
people are flourishing women are happy
men are happy this is the way to go bro
alhamdulillah
masha allah
and jazak look here for the super chat
may allah bless you
oh man you know we're going we're going
to keep that that part between me and
you bro
okay
next ask your kids about school and what
they learned today my parents did that
and they were able to teach me counter
arguments yeah that's true there's a
disconnect between a lot of let me let
me pin this down there's a disconnect
between a lot of men and women um at
least parents today in the west and
their kids the youth right the youth are
becoming the youth
but the reason they're
becoming i guess losing the dean is
because when they go to school there's
this false sense of authority oh look
it's my parents uh us not my parents oh
look it's my teachers oh look it's it's
people superior to me telling me what to
do i have to follow their instructions
to do well in school to get those a's to
get that good gpa and to succeed in the
academic education system
because i need to
listen to what they say
therefore everything they say is valid
it's coming from a place of legitimate
authority instead of you know why would
they lie you know it makes no sense so
this whole notion of subtle programming
when you go into school you begin to see
them say stuff like oh you need to
respect pronouns or you need a pronoun
or you need to crossdress and you're
like
they're right and parents are unaware of
this subhanallah to the point where it's
like you're doing your thing at the
dinner table and your son comes home
when your daughter comes home and you
say something that is islamically
permissible and your daughter's like dad
that's so barbaric that's so and you're
like bro what is this why i brought you
to you know the west and it's like this
whole dynamic it's like you all need to
connect with your kids you know
kevin
from ireland
this brother we did an episode with him
uh live shahada if you didn't check that
out marshall a beautiful brother uh five
the new vlog martial was beautiful man
jazakallah here barack
if you guys haven't seen his
you know video that we did with him it
was a very early video i think last year
like very early on
uh check that out and i have a ton of
respect for reverts i gotta say i'm sure
rami does too
because bro
allah knows best if we were born as
non-muslims if we would come into the
deen only allah is in control of that
and just seeing these brothers that they
completely changed their life
just takes up islam it really does
soften my heart
are you planning on moving to saudi
because i am
[Music]
[Music]
may allah reward you and grant you the
best for you and your kids
i mean i mean i mean
let's see there needs to be a huge push
for homeschooling imams and scholars
should begin to speak about it more so
it becomes more common rami what are
your thoughts yeah i agree 100 and the
reason i would say homeschooling over
islamic schools is because even islamic
schools they still have a criteria that
they have to meet because to have your
high school diploma there are certain
things you need to learn and if they
start in court incorporating things that
shouldn't be in islamic curriculum then
that's going to be problematic so um
i think that homeschooling would be
safest but if not at least more islamic
institutions islamic schools and i find
it unfortunate that a lot of the with
like aside from islam a lot of the time
when you go to some schools they're
really small
they're really small there's only maybe
like a 100 students so we need more of
those inshallah
the the speaker
uh when the lady asked about her job
you're muted bro
i was going to say that's a little late
but uh
okay guys last two minutes
how do you homeschool hire teachers
that's a good question
you you would teach your
your own children unless you i mean you
probably can hire a teacher as well but
you can hire a teacher it's still less
fit not than sending them into the fire
bro
all right last couple questions and then
let's wrap it up some welcome brother
i'm from bangladesh yo represent
secularism and toxic feminism is being
pushed highly in my country and now
practicing islam seems strange all right
bro i'm going to say something right now
that a lot of bengalis won't like but if
you're looking for islam
a lot of muslim countries that's not
where you're going to find it and my
experience with bangladesh it's pretty
weird like you know what i mean i'm not
going to say a lot of things because a
lot of my family watches the podcast but
i will say this
that this whole
narrative the western narrative that's
being pushed on y'all in bangladesh and
pakistan and india and all these
countries
is basically what's already happened for
us the last couple of years so it's like
now you guys are catching up to it and
i'm telling you right now it's gonna get
worse it's already written it's gonna
get worse before it gets better so just
hold tightly um you're gonna you're
gonna seem like a lunatic bro expect
that like reminding your family that you
know we shouldn't celebrate birthdays
because of haram and them them being
like bro what are you psycho like
we're just getting a cake we're just
we're not you know like what's wrong
with that and you're gonna be labeled
the bad guys they're gonna put you in a
box so expect that toughen up thicken
your skin and uh inshallah make series
for you i mean
[Music]
all right
three more questions and we're done the
youth suffers from entertainment
addiction which makes them repel okay do
you think an islamic state should
restrict accident healthy entertainment
of course 100
100 and and unhealthy should not be
something subjective
it should be something that is actually
like the scholars
they have agreed that this is something
generally you know because there are i
think social media and a lot of this
entertainment it has led to the decay of
society
okay writes how do you propose muslim
prepare for qiyamah rami this is all you
the way that allah the messenger
sallallahu alaihi told us to just
enjoying good forbid evil
remind those around us of the day of
qiyama and ask forgiveness from allah
constantly do the best that you can in
this life and expect mercy from allah
insha allah and know that allah is
merciful inshallah simple bro adam khan
writes i think allah places us
western-born muslims here for strategic
reason i wasn't born in the west
you weren't either right i was oh you
were okay yeah
um
but i think you know this applies to me
to and a lot of people that are here
i want to end it with this note that a
lot of our parents a lot of our families
a lot of the the muslims in the west
didn't come here or make hijrah for the
purpose of establishing the deen for the
purpose of dawa
but it doesn't mean that us descendants
we can't make that our intention we
can't do our part to try to revive islam
in the west
and ask yourself this
every single day
what did you do to push the needle
forward for the dean
than you did the day before and if you
didn't do anything then don't go to
sleep until you do it could be something
as simple as smiling to your neighbors
and showing them that muslims are good
people which we are
it could be something like you know
being good to your women being good to
your wives being good to your daughters
it could be something as simple as
forbidding evil where you see evil
helping someone in need giving sadaka it
could be anything but do something it's
better than doing nothing
but remember doing nothing is sometimes
better than doing something bad
which identity you guys from
i think he means ethnicity ethnicity i
don't i don't identify with all these
pronouns i am uh
100
bengali bro
and i am 100 percent palestinian
bro and would that send it off do you
think
that being said allah
and guys go in the description check out
the vlog what are you doing like i'm
gonna leave you with this all right
assalaamu alaikum